welcome to a brand-new season of battle
damage today we're addressing one of the
biggest tech rivalries of all time Mac
versus PC you've already picked aside
because everyone who uses a computer is
a Mac person or a PC person unless
you're one of those Linux freaks but
we're not going to talk about that and
thanks to suggestions from users plasma
plays survival of Scott and wits ax
we're going head-to-head with a MacBook
Air vs. surface pro 3
these two ultra portable machines have
similar tech specs and both start around
900 bucks but only the surface can
function as a laptop and a tablet thanks
to his touch screen and pen
functionality but only the MacBook Air
can run both OS 10 and Windows and let's
be honest it's a lot prettier I guess
the only way to settle this is to see
which one is tougher to the battle RAM
you know I plated this service I'm never
using before it's not that bad it's the
worst roll action okay this looks fine
this does have a little dent and it
doesn't maybe shut perfectly but still
works fine this surface is looking good
yeah it's funny that your MacBook Air
has little dents because this thing
looks flawless yeah kickstand man yeah
which means you can only get one angle
look at this that's so many angles
okay this is the most expensive single
drop we've ever done
Oh God okay let's make this happen roll
action
Oh doesn't look good
what's not on it totally are the keys
here we go okay so eighty-five dollars
of the surface is destroyed whatever it
was like it on for a second but now it's
totally broken okay so maybe more than
$85 destroyed oh wow but themes work
fine I mean you get a pair of pliers you
bend that back you could uh that just
gives a character so I think it's
actually improved it's gotten stronger
no no doesn't shut so good but I think
MacBook Aaron is moving on oh wait this
is the work wait wait
yes seems to be working so in further
inspection looks like the surface
actually does work so they're both gonna
move on for the next round
there just is no I use it for our third
and final test we're going back in time
and making each device face its worst
nightmare which for my PC is the dreaded
blue screen of death and for my MacBook
the spinning pinwheel of death and to
keep it interesting we filled each one
with 50 pounds of concrete first up the
MacBook Air roll action
is it broken
wow it's so dented but internal it'll
work you could theoretically plug this
into a monitor and a new keyboard still
use it as a computer this is impressive
alright let's test the surface this is
definitely the most awkward thing I
think we've ever had the drop speed roll
action
Oh surface I mean I just loved that it
followed it up Highschool think it's
gonna turn on oh my god are you kidding
oh oh there's a screen it does look like
the surface is not turning on so I'm
keeping that pen this is this is what's
left Oh No even the pen is broken crap
we made all right looks like macbook air
has officially won well there you have
it now you know whether you should go
Mac or PC that is if you're the kind of
person who plans on dropping your
computer from a crane 15 feet in the air
totally irrelevant test sometimes stuff
happens man what's the worst thing
you've ever done to your computer let us
know in the comments below hover your
mouse over that subscribe button and
firmly click so you don't miss our next
episode gonna be a good one
you